good morning John and Merry Christmas I
have good news finally come up with and
have a pen here because I was doing
calculations charities that are being
funded through the project for awesome
we have coming in fifth place with 915
votes the kind foundation kids in need
of deaths thanks to an amazing video
dark horse candidate out of nowhere
really fantastic work in 4th place with
one thousand forty three votes we have
kiva.org now there are two things going
on with Kiva at any given time one
running the actual service of Kiva
allowing people to connect with
entrepreneurs in the developing world so
we have the actual entrepreneurs who can
be funded not through donations but
through loans and so what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna split that in half
half of its going to go to running and
maintaining kiva.org and the other half
is going to go into loans for
entrepreneurs number three with one
thousand three hundred and ninety three
votes we have the Harry Potter Alliance
there's bateria knows what it's doing in
second place with exactly two thousand
votes we have water.org the one that I
suggested thanks everybody and in first
place with two thousand two hundred and
twenty four votes we have that this star
won't go out foundation each one of
these charities will be getting fourteen
thousand two hundred sixty nine dollars
and 22 cents because that is the seventy
one thousand H dollars that we got for
the foundation to creat will suck
divided by 5 H 5 gets piece of that now
in order to continue the celebration of
this Christmas season that we are in I'm
gonna do a truther fail on Christmas
carols but first here is the most
interesting comment judge judged by me
from the last view but getting a poster
and there is no poster in this video
I've noticed so leave an interesting
comment anyway you can't have my
Christmas tree hello and welcome to
another edition of truth or fail it's a
very simple game show and which I tell
you to purported facts and you click on
the true one or you fail today's episode
of truth or fail is so amazing that
you're gonna want to wrap it up and put
it underneath your Christmas tree for
your family since we have just
officially ended the holiday season
because I guess that's what happens on
December 26 we are no longer going to be
hearing Christmas carols constantly but
I know that you as a smart intelligent
and curious person want to know about
these peculiar pieces of music so today
we're doing truth to fail on Christmas
carols
number one the 12 days of Christmas now
everybody knows this song it's the world
with the five gold rings but did you
know that every year
PNC Wealth Management calculates the
combined worth of all of the items that
your true love gave to you and the most
expensive of all of the items this year
was the seven swans a-swimming which if
you purchased them outright would cost
you 60 three hundred dollars or fact
number two the entirety of the twelve
days of Christmas is copyrighted and
cannot be performed on this show it was
originally written in 1909 and the
copyright has been extended so many
times that it still exists to this day